ah in her new book a good time to be a
girl Dame Helena Morrissey set out her
store for greater equality she was well
versed having struggled to reach the
city summit all while being a mum to
nine children so on the 100th
anniversary of women's suffrage what
does she make of the me to campaign the
BBC payro and the female fight still to
be waged the BBC needs to do something
fast about that injustice I hugely
sympathise with the women I'm very much
Pro the publication of gender pay data
there is no excuse for unequal pay the
gender pay gap the average difference
between male and female earnings
obviously might take a bit longer to fix
and that's we've got to make sure that
women are valued though for the skills
we bring not that you have to be like a
man to be as valuable as a man we
shouldn't have to ask for a pay rise to
be given a pay rise we should be given a
pay rise because we've earned that so I
have huge empathy and I'm just surprised
that it's not being gripped to have no
pants by BBC management and resolved
what would you say to Tony Hall I would
say make this your legacy do something
about this and other thing you might
well say okay so it's very difficult to
do something when I haven't got
unlimited funds and not all the men are
going to take a pay cut but there the
publication of the PwC report that
showed there was no real framework for
analyzing pay and assessing pay you know
this is not something that you could
then spend years correcting just make
this your legacy I'd say I've spoken to
a couple of lawyers who are representing
women and they say it can get very
unpleasant yes and I completely
understand why people might feel
reticent particularly if it's going to
make they'll feel initially that now
they've got to go through quite
stressful and negotiations and a case
and I think now the such big spotlight
on the issue not only where women will
be heard with a speaker speaker but most
in companies I do I'm part like a social
media I mean ultimately people can share
their stories can't they in a way that
they were never able to do before it
would be just between them and their
employer and now there's so much concern
whether they just share that by a glass
door anonymously but people will look
and see what's been reported on the
company if you have grounds then speak
up
we will be heard if you're not heard
there are legal mechanisms obviously
they can be quite painful and difficult
to go through but most smart companies
now that the very mere thought that they
will be exposed if they are doing
something wrong will address it before
it gets to that point I'm always a bit
confused when people talk about feminism
what does it mean to you because it
means something different to all of us
young so for me it means striving for
gender equality as simple as that
and I say I mean that that is sharing
work life family not pigeonholing
people not putting straitjackets around
men and requiring them just to have a
full time career and be the breadwinner
so forth it means real equality and for
me then I'm proud to be a feminist I
realize the words got charged as you say
it means militancy in some reporters I'm
not a militant feminist at all I when I
was writing the book I was looking
through some of the things that happened
when I was a child and certainly I
recall the conversations about women's
rights and women's lib when I was a
little girl and then there seemed to be
I was very conscious of perception you
couldn't be either you had to be either
a feminine feminist or feminine you
couldn't be broke I'm trying to be a
feminine feminist suffragettes obviously
hundredth anniversary today Emily
Pancoast I was reading an article about
her over the weekend describing her as a
terrorist so obviously their methods
included violence and but it wasn't
violence against people there was a
violence against property although
obviously sometimes one strayed into the
other I in one of the speeches then
there was this amazing little story
where a woman went in and broke the
windows of the guards club and the
guards came out and said why he broke in
our windows we've done nothing and the
woman suffragettes said it's because
you've done nothing I broke in your
windows and they did it to get attention
and ultimately it was successful
nowadays I don't think we need to use
those sorts of methods and I think it's
important not to sort of glorify
violence in any way but actually
recognize that those women who often
sacrificed in their
this place in society everything felt so
strongly that this was the only way do
you think where we are now it's is
cyclical and we are at a high point as
women and we will find ourselves in a
position where we go back round full
circle and not find ourselves where we
are again for another 30 or 40 years it
is a great time to be a girl as you say
but potentially if we pushed it too far
with things like the me to campaign I do
think we're at one of those critical
junctures so I think to make further
progress we need to work with men and
recognize that they're very very many
men I'll have no idea about being no
desire to predator or never would have
been and are shocked as well we need to
have male allies I just don't want us to
go back into the gender war mentality if
we go back into the gender war mentality
we will set ourselves back and it won't
be if you're interested in progress I
mean I understand the point about making
a point and I'm saying we should speak
up but if your interest in making
progress we have to work with men and we
have to work towards this idea and
helped by young people I mean I think
that's the other thing to make sure we
don't you know senior women and senior
men don't just stick to the resolution
of issues that have built up over many
years since we've been working but think
about what the young people both are
seeing from our example but then what
well how they want to work the ways of
working and listen to them and bring
them into the conversation do you ever
wish you'd been a man no I've never
thought of that I mean I suppose when I
was in the middle of childbirth I might
[Laughter]
enjoy being a girl I enjoyed the I felt
in the city although I'm claiming you
know that there was no plane sailing at
all especially in the early years then
later on it was it was quite helpful
standing out there would be a sea of men
in st. pinstripe suits I me and my dress
and you know I did get notice I did get
asked to do things I did offer to do
things and good career opportunities and
I think we need to remember that as well
sometimes that sometimes as a benefit
even when there may be some other
impediments or
it's you know it's I do believe it's a
good time to be a girl
final thoughts on on that that's the
name of the book of course some women
don't like being called a girl what
would you say to them the emphasis on
girls is partly cuz I see the next
generation my daughters having the
opportunity to behave as women whereas I
in my early career did up to at least
get a seat at that table that was mostly
populated by the men and I think that's
my emphasis is you know we're looking
forward I think we can make a much
better situation than just extrapolating
the past by thinking more boldly about
this gender equality point but I hope I
don't offend anybody by linking them in
with that I just think we should
celebrate the fact that we have
something very specific to offer
something the men don't have often in
terms of how we think how we work and I
think we should enjoy them have a Marisa
thank you thank you